In this segment, we will derive
the formula for the
variance of the geometric PMF.
The argument will be very much
similar to the argument that
we used to drive the expected
value of the geometric PMF.
And it relies on the
memorylessness properties of
geometric random variables.
So let X be a geometric
random variable with
some parameter p.
The way to think about X is like
the number of coin flips
that it takes until we obtain
heads for the first time,
where p is the probability
of heads at each toss.
Recall now the memorylessness
property.
If I tell you that X
is bigger than 1--
which means that the first
trial was a failure---
we obtained tails.
Given that event, the remaining
number of tosses has
the same geometric PMF
as if we were just
starting at this time.
So it has the same geometric PMF
as the unconditional PMF
of X. And this is the property
that we exploited in order to
find the expected value of X.
Now let us take this observation
and add one to the
random variables involved and
turn this statement to the
following version.
The conditional PMF of X--
which is this random
variable plus 1--
is the same as the unconditional
PMF of this
random variable plus 1.
So it's the same statement as
before except that we added 1.
One consequence of the
memorylessness that we have
already seen and exploited is
that the expected value of X
in the conditional universe
where the first coin flip was
wasted is equal to 1--
that's the wasted coin flip--
plus how long you expect to have
to flip the coin until
you obtain heads for the
first time, starting
from the second flip.
Since the conditional
distribution of X in this
universe is the same as the
unconditional distribution of
this random variable, it means
that the corresponding
expected value in this universe
is going to be equal
to the expected value of this
random variable, which is 1
plus the expected value of X.
And by exactly the same
argument, the random variable
X squared has the same
distribution in the conditional
universe as the
random variable X plus
1 squared in the
unconditional universe.
So since X in the conditional
universe has the same
distribution as X plus 1, it
means that X squared in the
conditional universe has the
same distribution as X plus 1
squared in the unconditional
universe.
So now let us take those facts
and use a divide and conquer
method to calculate the expected
value of X squared.
We will use exactly the same
method that we used in order
to calculate the
expected value.
We separate into
two scenarios.
In one scenario, X
is equal to 1.
And then we have the expected
value of X squared given that
X is equal to 1.
And then we have another
scenario--
the scenario that X
is bigger than 1.
And then we have the expected
value of X squared given that
X is bigger than 1.
So this is just the total
expectation theorem.
Now let us calculate terms.
The probability that the first
toss results in success, that
X is equal to 1-- this is p.
And if X is equal to 1, then the
value of X squared is also
equal to 1.
And then there is probability 1
minus p that the first trial
was not a success.
So we get to continue.
We have this conditional
expectation here.
But it is equal to this
unconditional
expectation up there.
And now let us expand the terms
in this quadratic and
write this as expected value
of X squared plus twice the
expected value of X plus 1.
Now we know what this expected
value here is.
The expected value of a
geometric is just 1/p.
And what we're left with is an
equation that involves a
single unknown.
Namely, this quantity
is the unknown.
And we can solve this linear
equation for this unknown.
We carry out some algebra,
which is not so
interesting by itself.
And after we carry out the
algebra, what we obtain is
that the expected value of X
squared is equal to 2 over p
squared minus 1 over p.
And then we use the formula that
the variance of a random
variable is equal to the
expected value of the square
of that random variable
minus the square of
the expected value.
We already know what that
expected value is.
We found the expected
value of the square.
And putting all that together,
we obtain a final answer.
And this is the expression for
the variance of a geometric
random variable.
It goes without saying that for
this calculation to make
sense, we need to assume that
the parameter that we're
dealing with is positive.